i mean it's nice to say you're a mess
you know i mean you haven't been like
very open about your struggles with with
uh with drugs and alcohol i thought
maybe we could kind of peer into this
um so so you are super candid about it
and um like as somebody who follows you
on social media like
it seems that that um
like all the time you're posting hey if
you need help like with with your issues
with addiction yeah then call me yeah
and you include a phone number there is
that actually your number in your pocket
like it would be ringing all day so i
have two phones that i carry around one
is that number and if i don't answer
that like if it doesn't work with what
i'm doing like right now then it goes
through to a team of people that help
aid and assist that person with whatever
their situation is okay what's the
success rate of somebody calling you and
getting help and staying sober i mean
not that there's a percentage but is it
common i mean do people actually go
through on yeah totally you know what's
it's you have to weed it out it's like
scott knows better than like everything
success rates in general with addiction
are like they're just terrible yeah it
makes it very undesirable if you look at
the stats like you just think you're
fighting the unwinning calls yeah that's
how i felt when i first heard the
statistics and i was in rehab in 1995
and i was only 20 years old and i was
like wait 95 of the alcoholics don't get
sober like then why would i even bother
and the statistics kept me loaded
totally but then once i was ready yeah i
could argue that the statistics kept me
sober because i knew that the odds were
so against me that i had to just like do
everything in my power to give myself an
advantage and and it really like made me
take it seriously and so i stayed in
sober living until i had two years i did
all this stuff to like
really give myself the advantage and and
that's
you know really why i'm still around
that's my [ __ ] approach exactly like
you know obviously
i
i [ __ ] i loved drugs and alcohol i
couldn't get enough right dude let's not
say that in the past tense right i mean
[ __ ] dude
yeah i would love to get it
but now it's like i i get off on like
the sobriety part of it right it's the
kind of the closest connection that i
have with that past so it works for me
so me like you
i remember going to treatment like this
half of the room's dead this is half of
the room look to your right your left
two of those are dead i'm like right now
i think they're going to say they said
okay look around there's 12 of you only
one of you is going to make it like
that's what the statistics are dude why
am i wasting admire your times [ __ ]
get loaded and do that and so when i got
sober i'm like dude [ __ ] statistics
because the statistics state that i
should be higher dead right now and i'm
not and it defies odds and logics so
like if i can do it why the [ __ ] can't
you right i think that's
the problem is that the statistics are
for like alcoholics and
addicts at large whereas like when
people actually
get serious about recovery and start
doing the things that we do then all of
a sudden the statistics are a whole
different deal yeah they don't even
exist really yeah if you
get into this program of recovery and do
the things we do
then it's a pretty simple process yeah
but let me ask you this because it's
something that that occurs to me kind of
a lot you know being someone who follows
you like how
just about every post that you put on
instagram like it almost invariably is
related to your recovery yeah and then
and and so i think my question is
how
many people
have expressed concern that like whoa
you know like you're putting it out
there so much that like we worry about
you sure
some have right like the people that are
pretty close to me have
because because i identify as one of
those people i i think man
like
novak's putting it out there so much
like as like his identity yeah that like
it feels like you know i'm like scared
like i i just worry about it well
thank you for that right like that and
that that's what friends are for yeah i
do um and for me i kind of treat it as
like a an
added layer of safety right like i'm
such an extremist and i'm such a [ __ ]
all or nothing that
it kind of adds a little more to like
the
what helps keep me like wanting to do
this like i could easily sneak and let
myself down and no one will know so it's
like jumping out of a plane with two
parachutes as opposed to one if that
makes any sense i mean i just think like
here's what creeps me out and it creeps
me out so much
when i heard that
um the people
with the highest rates of relapse are
people who work in recovery yeah i mean
it's so counterintuitive if you imagined
that like
like you know the people who died of
cancer the most were doctors who worked
with cancer patients it's like
you should know right right it's it's
counter-intuitive absolutely terrible
example with the cancer thing but um but
it just makes me like think you know
like i want to be so careful to not ever
like professionalize yeah require to let
that become the identity of the industry
right dude i had this one experience
where uh
what like i i got i got uh hired to go
um to a university and they did
i was to just do an on stage q a about
mental health and i didn't even think
about either paying me like you know an
obnoxious amount of money to go out and
like answer questions i'd go on stage
and like
and and very quickly every question that
they asked me about mental health my
answer i would find was like oh well you
know i kind of only really know like
like addictions i can't speak to
you know like like all the various
mental health issues but like you know i
see everything kind of through the prism
of of just like you know addiction and
alcoholism and recovery and then like
very quickly i realized oh my god like
i'm here getting paid to share the
message of recovery and the scariest
thing of all was after i got done i i
had this thought flash through my mind
which was
oh well dude if everything dries up and
comedy doesn't work out and like this or
that like i mean i suppose i could go
around getting paid to talk about
recovery and then i was like
no
you know i'm like that's that's what
scares me the most sure
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's
selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]